les et guti était aussi dans la rue
réunis devant le ministère des finances
près de 200 et goûter de la ville de
paris ont déposé ce matin leur bleu de
travail en signe de protestation
avec une espérance de vie inférieure de
17 ans à la moyenne générale selon
l'étude de l'inserm et ses
professionnels lutte contre une réforme
qui va les contraindre à prendre leur
retraite plus tard une retraite à 62 ans
au lieu de 52 ans avec la suppression de
la catégorie insalubre dont ils font
partie
si on a pu leur faire goûter la plupart
des gens qui vous doit descendre dans
les aigus quotidiennement un égoutier
l'exposer à des insectes à deraa des
plus vous pouvez les pieds dans la merde
quand vous tirez votre chasse d'eau les
écoutilles marche dedans on a retrouvé
de l'amiante maintenant après la séance
de notre d'armes à trouver du plô
quotidiennement un égoutier exploser ça
et maintenant on nous dit quoi on dit on
casse le système maintenant c'est 60 de
son ballon ne trouve pas donc on a
choisi le ministère de l'économie et des
finances aujourd'hui pour montrer les
victimes de la réforme des retraites à
savoir les égoutter avec la fin de la
catégorie active et de nos de notre
statut
aujourd'hui avec l'espérance de vie de
17 ans réduite pour les égoutiers on
partira à la retraite et on sera mort et
jean luc mélenchon étaient présents à
leurs côtés pour le leader de la france
soumise
le gouvernement doit retirer cette
réforme
je crois qu'il faut qu'il retire son
texte et vous vous rendez compte ce type
est violé dans ce pays les droits
constitutionnels à manifester les gens
se font éborgné maintenant on a peur
qu'on cas des policiers après vous avez
une violence économique l'économie du
pays souffrent à faut pas dire un peux
pas faut pas s'en cacher d'ailleurs la
grèce mais pour ça n'est pas fait pour
favoriser les affaires bon l'économie
soûlé personnes souffrent parce que la
grève les retenues de salaire mais
maintenant c'est la démocratie le
parlement on va nous faire voter un
texte et que des trous dans dans quelle
démocratie ça existe un truc pareil
vous avez une loi avec des textes
inachevés avec des trous dedans où ça
existe
ton me montre un endroit où c'est
possible